my big question is do you think or do
you know if tim cook watches this show
because if he watches it i'm gonna get
to keep seeing it for a long time
[Laughter]
i know he's seen it and i know he does
like it
uh i couldn't tell you where he is and
how how much
he's kept up with it but i know uh he's
uh he's he is
a fan of the show i do know that i know
i wish you were making all the decisions
about how long we're on the air
yeah yes my decisions would be yes
you definitely would want me uh making
the decisions um so we know that star
trek exists
in for all mankind uh you have a nice
little
moment with the in season two my big
question of course is does battlestar
galactica
exist in for all mankind
i think it probably does i think i think
glenn larson probably still made
uh the original battlestar galactica and
i don't know if it it might have kept
going further because i kind of felt
that
because there was so much interest in
space and that there was a space mania
even bigger than what we remember going
on in the 70s and the 80s that
that show might have continued i think
star trek phase two probably
actually happened in the mid 70s you
know i think there was probably a big
boom in
pop culture and and space projects wait
can i ask you a question here is
sorry i'm taking over this interview
what did ron moore do in the for all
mankind alternate history
oh that's an interesting question i
think i probably would have really tried
to stay in the navy to become an
astronaut which is really what i
i wanted to do and i was afraid that my
math skills were going to be too
would not have made it i might have
buckled down if it had been more of a
real thing
oh that's great uh for fans of the show
i hate asking the generic thing but what
what do you want to tease people about
season two
well it's uh it's the cold war you know
in the military and that becomes a big
part of the story
in season two we're in the 80s it's the
reagan era the competition with the
soviet union really heats up and
uh and the confrontation with the soviet
union happens not just on earth but in
space and on the moon itself so that's
really what season two
is about and i also would add that i
think the relationships that we've come
to know and love
have changed and they've evolved and uh
we'll see kind of new
sides of those relationships as we go
over season two
one of the things about this series is
that there are so many
places you could tell the story and you
have all these characters and locations
what is it like trying to figure out
where you want to actually spend your
time
because i mean there's so many choices
yeah i mean it takes a lot of work in
the writer's room to figure all that out
because we could take the story in so
many
different directions and we have a
fairly wide cat a
fairly large cast that's getting bigger
all the time so you really have to sort
of pick and choose
where you're going to spend time and it
changes and evolves you know the the
course that we set out at the beginning
of the season often
changes as we realize we don't have
enough time to do everything that we
would that we
uh set out to do so we have to sort of
make sacrifices or
make changes in the plot and stories to
just kind of get it down to
you know it's fighting weight and do the
do the best show that we can
when you're making season two are you
starting to think about okay well
we might get five years we better figure
out where we're ultimately going
and how much is it we're sort of taking
it season by season well
from the beginning we decided that we
had to map out the whole thing because
the nature of the show was so intricate
and you're dealing with history and time
lines and you know how certain events
are going to happen and we wanted to
roll it out
in a specific way so that we could see
you know the progression of the space
program over the course of decades
so we actually mapped out the whole
journey way back before the beginning of
season one and we're trying to sort of
keep to that to keep to that schedule
which we have done more or less you know
everything kind of changes within the
margins
but the big goal posts and the big ideas
of what's going to happen have remained
the same
also i think like with any show you know
once you get to know your actors better
and
and also you see how characters resonate
i think that always does kind of
influence how you move ahead
well one of the things about this series
for me is that
it's really it's starting at the
beginning and it's clear that you guys
as you've said you have a place you're
going but do you already know what
season would introduce a starship
basically but we're not going to tell
you
it's not soon of course i i i'm just
curious if that's come up in the
writer's room and you know
because you know season 2 sort of is
touching on
the advancement of what you guys are
doing with nasa and i'm just curious you
know
if that's even come up well we talked we
do talk about the show being
this is the road that takes you to star
trek like this is how you get
you could get there and this is probably
what some version of this happened in
the
in the star trek backstory where you
know mankind went much more aggressively
into space than we did in reality
and there was technological advancement
and there was cultural change societies
change
the world starts coming together and you
know there's there's sort of a
generalized path
that takes you to starships and some in
some future
like star trek and so this show is sort
of trying to say well this is
basically how you kind of get there do
you guys envision i mean the fir from
season one to season two is about a 10
year jump
do you envision that each season will do
like a time jump and you'll use the
seasons
to do that that's the basic concept is
like each each year each season we would
jump
roughly a decade or so ahead so that uh
because at the outset we wanted to see
how the space program could develop
and that takes time if we just set the
show in the 70s you had never gotten out
of
the apollo skylab era so we wanted to
really see the space program
expand and and have really lofty
ambitions
so that required a much bigger time
frame and then part of the fun of that
is seeing how your characters change in
in 10-year jumps and kid kids grow into
adults and adults age out of the program
there's a churn of cast of characters
and that's part of the fun of the show
one of the things i loved about the
first season is that you have an after
the credits scene
at the end of episode 10. is that
something that you're planning on
continuing each season like a little
tease of what's to come we might not
always do a uh
uh post credit sequence but we're always
gonna probably tease you know what's the
next jump it's at some point and
towards the end i love all your
questions because they're very you you
um
obviously are very detail-oriented in
the show you asked all the questions
we're not quite sure if we can answer
yeah right i apologize the last time i
have to rap but
the last time i interviewed i
interviewed the director of one division
and he felt like he
was at a deposition and i'm like i'm
just
i'm just a fan and i want to know things
so you know
i mean what can i say um i gotta go i'm
just gonna say congrats i'm really a
huge fan of the series
and um uh when the when i finally get to
see episode 10 i would love to do a
follow-up and actually
talk about the specifics you know um
listen have a great day thank you so
much
thank you thank you